[Music]
the expectation of really all people now
is that they're going to know what
happened the instant it happens and you
know that's great when the information
is accurate I think the downside of just
so many stories circulating at any given
microsecond is that people feel somewhat
overwhelmed by news and you know it's
hard to focus your attention on what
stories are most important when they're
exploding at you usually now reporters
break their stories on Twitter before
they've even written a finished story
first that nuance and perspective and
analysis can be completely lost in that
first quick and dirty version but worse
there can be big factual mistakes which
you know has contributed you know the
very low trust numbers that all news
media companies have right now which is
very distressing to me because it opens
the door for President Trump to rant
about fake news and call journalists the
enemies of the people when they're like
the heroes of the people because they
risk their lives to dig out the
information that is vital for people to
know when I started as a reporter in the
Stone Age of course you know Newton the
newsroom was you know I always thought
it would be like Jimmy Olsen and
Superman that you know you'd hear
typewriters clacking and people shouting
and I was surprised at how quiet at
least the Wall Street Journal's newsroom
in Washington was and there was no
internet at that point and the rhythm of
the
des was usually in the morning and
through the afternoon you were out
reporting you were finding sources going
to hearings you know meeting secretly
with people who might give you documents
uh and really you only got around to
writing your story about 6:00 p.m. and
the deadline you know you could set your
watch by it every night was around 9:00
because the rhythm of newspaper in was
completely governed by when the presses
rolled and they only rolled once a day
unless the earth blew up and then you
stopped the presses and replayed it but
you know it was a slow pace and the
journal when I had joined up didn't even
have a weekend paper so fry it Friday it
was really an easy day because the next
paper was Monday and then all changed in
the late 1990s with the advent of the
Internet and the Wall Street Journal was
one of the first newspapers to create an
online version of itself and that meant
that the printing presses didn't figure
into like when your story when although
in the early years it was ridiculous it
was true at the times too we maintain
that same schedule of just doing one
final story a day at night and then
having it posted on the web for years
but the advent of social media
completely changed that and what had
become a much faster pace where you know
at the times we were posting early
versions of any important store
on nytimes.com and with social media it
was the instantaneous report like get
something up on social media to like
begin attracting the eyeballs before you
even have a story up on the website that
began to actually scare me when I became
Washington bureau chief of the times and
the Supreme Court had just it was night
time decided Bush v Gore decided what
would happen next if anything and who
would be president and the instant t v--
analysis on CNN and other cable outlets
was wrong and Linda greenhouse who was
the times as totally experienced
brilliant supreme court reporter you
know rush back to the office with she
had read the decision in a cab and the
first thing she said to us when she
arrived was turn off the TV because she
knew they were blathering idiocy and
then she she told us it was over Bush
won and that night so stuck in my mind
and roll the cameras forward to the
decision on Obamacare when I was
executive editor I wasn't you know
calling the Washington bureau to say
have that story first
the second there's a decision I wanted
up I was worried about the opposite I
was worried about a repeat of that's
Bush v Gore nigh and my instructions
were until the supreme court reporter
and the Washington bureau chief call me
and say their Shore and it was you
remember a clue
decision we are not putting anything up
and if quite a bit of time goes by we'll
clue in readers that we're reporting the
story for them but we're not gonna do a
quick draw mcgraw
[Music]